the rise of the data economy has
companies finding enormous value in
collecting sharing and using personal
data
however with this wealth of information
floating around
companies are increasingly under threat
from data breaches and cyber attacks and
it is imperative organizations have the
right mindset when it comes to their
customers and clients personal data with
udacity's new data privacy course
students will understand the core
foundations of data privacy from both a
business and practitioner perspective
and will be positioned to help their
organization strategize to ensure their
data is safe in this course students
will learn how to evaluate the data
privacy risks associated with different
types of data that they collect use and
share
ask critical questions about privacy
issues from business legal and cultural
perspectives
and analyze the trade-offs of common
privacy approaches such as aggregating
or anonymizing the personally
identifiable information of their
customers or employees
students will leave the course with a
holistic view of data privacy issues in
business a data privacy checklist for
use in future projects and industry
guided best practices that can be
implemented in physical or virtual
office environments
enroll in udacity's data privacy course
today